je m'appelle Peter, je vois beaucoup de ceintures et je
suis né en 1972 à Goomer, pas dans le nord du
Groenland, et j'y ai vécu les
12 premières années de ma vie avec mes parents et mes
trois sœurs aînées, moi et ma mère
quand la pêche tous les jours nous  avoir ceci
en danois ils les appellent vous savez
directement traduits ils s'appellent de longues
lignes je ne sais pas comment ils l'appellent en
anglais c'est une longue ligne avec
beaucoup de crochets et vous rangez
et ce curseur un gros  chose en métal avec
ça avec un caillou dessus et puis vous le
glissez sous les yeux comme ça en
étirant les crochets en bas et à la
fin vous laissez tomber un poids et ensuite vous avez
tous les crochets dans une centaine de canulars
plus bas en bas  pêcher le flétan
et ces poissons sont certainement allés chercher les chiens
et se sont battus pour nous-mêmes, alors chaque jour
, ma mère et moi en hiver, presque tous les
jours, ma mère et moi
sommes sortis et avons obtenu ces longues lignes et nous sommes arrivés sur
le site et avons coupé le trou  encore une fois
qui a gelé au nord au cours de th  e nuit
sont les deux nuits selon combien de
jours nous ne sommes pas allés le chercher
et puis nous avons changé tu sais j'ai
commencé par marcher je ne sais pas 100
mètres puis ma mère a pris le relais et toi
détroit de la longue file vous le
savez et le soleil brille les pourparlers
attendent que demander de plus
et votre famille avait-elle une équipe de chiens ou oui
nous avions un chien vu que les habitants
nous ont apporté une chienne ou quoi faire  tu l'
appelles et au pire que
c'est celui qui va te faire la
meute quand il sera grand et et pourra
accoucher c'est un câlin ou comme
tu l'appelles là tant pis et ce chien
est venu dans un sac ce petit  chienne que vous
connaissez presque née avec les 6-8 semaines
et elle s'appelait Busia
qui est de retour en 84 il n'y avait pas de
championnats nucléaires de boogie électrique
et de breakdance et nous arrivions ici
à logan je pense que c'était en août ou
quelque chose juillet tu  savoir juin juillet août
ou quelque chose et moi si je ne me souviens pas
mal c'est w  en octobre ou quelque chose comme ça que
ces championnats ont eu lieu et vous
savez après être resté ici à New
pendant quelques mois, j'étais en fait dans
les championnats, donc je suis tout de suite dans la culture hip hop et je me suis
mêlé à elle
et j'ai commencé à danser comme le  première
partie et à partir de là, je suis passé au DJing
et à un peu de graffiti principalement sur
papier mais je ne suis pas le grand peintre donc
ce n'est pas mon côté fort j'ai une grande
gueule et beaucoup de mots en
sortent donc je  a fini par écrire des paroles après je
pense que c'était les rythmes et le
flow du rap et des trucs comme ça et
puis le message est venu avec Grandmaster
Flash et puis ça a pris un tour et j'ai
remarqué ce qu'on pouvait faire
avec la musique et surtout  enveloppé c'est-à-
dire que je pense que cela ressemble plus à une des
formes de communication les plus directes à
travers la musique si vous devez prendre une
douche, donc les lapins directement à l'
auditeur que vous connaissez et Anna écoutent pour dire
oh c'est de la musique rap, vous savez en quelque sorte
que cette personne parle  ng à propos de
l'expérience personnelle parce que c'est ce que
Revis fait habituellement, bien sûr, vous avez
le grand public qui devait gagner de l'argent sur les
pistes du Club et des trucs comme ça et c'est
vous savez mais c'est une
forme de communication forte et je pense que c'est
ce que j'ai pensé et
et m'a gardé sur la scène du rap et tu
sais que j'ai gardé l'intérêt pour le hip hop
quand nous avons commencé avec nuke posse
c'était plus comme l'intérêt du hip hop
qui nous maintenait ensemble tu sais que nous aimons
ce hip hop dont nous venons de différents
tous les milieux sociaux et de tous les
niveaux sociaux donc et et ce qui l'a maintenu
ensemble était la morosité du hip hop, vous
savez parce que nous étions assez différents
si si je peux dire mais ce que nous nous entendions
bien et nous avons fait ces premiers
morceaux de rap groenlandais et  et c'était
amusant de vivre dur comme je l'ai fait avec trop d'
alcool et trop de haschisch pendant plusieurs
années, vous savez, et non pas que dès le premier
jour où j'ai pris ma première paire, je suis devenu
fou, mais vous savez, au fil des ans, il
est devenu  trop d'alcool et
trop de tabac et tellement d'obscurité
dans ma vie, vous savez, et pendant toutes
ces années de forte consommation d'alcool, de
tabagisme et de fête, pas que tout était
mauvais, il y avait beaucoup de
fêtes amusantes et quelque part le long
du chemin, mais il  c'est devenu mauvais pour moi tu
sais que ce n'était plus bon pour moi et
il a fallu un certain temps pour arriver au point
où je devais faire quelque chose à ce sujet
c'était mon partenaire dans la vie qui
m'a dit certaines choses tu sais nous je
atteint le fond et elle me faisait la leçon
comme si j'étais un peu était comme un
enseignant ou une mère qui vous
parlait je n'avais pas je n'avais plus de mensonges j'avais
je ne pouvais pas je ne pouvais pas accuser quelqu'un d'
autre que moi-même vous savez  en essayant,
elle était tout le monde pour ma
consommation excessive d'alcool et ma vie comme moi, mais vous
savez, c'était moi qui prenais la bière,
c'était moi qui fumais, donc ça s'est terminé avec moi
avec l'aide de mon mon partenaire de vie et
et je  C'était le moment où j'ai dû aller
en cure de désintoxication et je suis allé en cure de désintoxication  c'était
ici à nouveau ici à Nuuk pendant neuf semaines
pour abus d'alcool et de haschich et ces
années de cœur vivant et de ne pas être
si bon avec moi-même m'ont donné beaucoup d'
autres choses, vous savez, j'ai vu des choses
que je pourrais vendre hmm  comme quoi
comme les côtés sombres du Groenland si vous
pouviez appeler ça que vous connaissez le
social l'aspect social les problèmes sociaux
et parlez-nous de certains des
problèmes sociaux au Groenland je vais sortir bien
sûr et et toute cette étape de de
de  la culture de la chasse, vous connaissez la pêche,
la culture de la chasse à cet
intérêt industriel, vous savez ce que vous appelez cela l'
industrialisation ou quoi au large du Groenland
du Groenland, vous savez, nous avons traversé
cela en 10 50 ans, vous savez, des
chasseurs à ce travail sur terre
et en prenant des études et  ne pas vivre
par la nature, vous savez, laissez la nature obliger
la nature à s'installer, mais maintenant vous
devez vous réveiller et aller à l'école et
vous mettre au travail, donc ce processus a été
très court, je pense, par rapport à d'autres
autres pays  ies en développement, vous savez que ce
développement a été le Groenland a traversé
cela en très peu de temps et cela a
créé des gens qui ne sont pas éduqués, vous
savez
oups de personnes qui ne sont pas éduquées et qui
ne reçoivent pas d'éducation et et cela a
créé des perdants associés si vous devriez
si vous pouvez appeler  c'est que vous savez social
ce que vous appelez des parias sociaux ouais
vous le savez et vous savez que nous nous sommes
suicidés parce que les gens ne se sentent peut-être pas
dignes de quoi que ce soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'éducation, vous savez que tout ce changement
a fait un lama que vous connaissez dans le  wagon
le dace le mari le chasseur était
tu sais important et ils ne pouvaient pas
vivre sans lui et maintenant tu as
ça c'est éduquer tbell et et c'était
surtout des dames et les hommes que tu connais
ne pouvaient pas trouver sa place d'une manière ou d'une autre je pense que
tu sais  où dois-je appartenir maintenant pour que
le développement du pays la courte
période de temps que le pari que le
développement de la chasse à aujourd'hui
ait traversé a coûté aux
gens sur vous  savoir avoir des problèmes d'
alcool et de suicide et un alcool
apporter toutes sortes d'autres choses vous savez
que j'ai utilisé et abusé vous savez l'abus sexuel
et le viol et aussi tous ces trucs viennent
avec l'alcool et donc c'est un gros mauvais
cocktail que ça a apporté  mais encore une fois,
je pense qu'il est important où nous en
sommes maintenant dans le temps que nous acceptions
ces problèmes tels qu'ils sont et les affrontons
et n'essayons pas de les dissimuler et de dire que
non ce n'est pas comme ça c'est mon peuple qui
a des enfants qui ne meurent pas de faim au
Groenland  et regardons-les en face et vous
savez quel pays n'a pas de problèmes,
cela peut avoir du sens pour certaines personnes et
peut-être les amener à emprunter un chemin un peu plus
court jusqu'à ce point où j'en suis
dans ma vie, vous savez en pensant à tout ce que
le  l'alcool et des trucs comme ça si je
peux raccourcir les routes de quelqu'un à
travers toute cette obscurité c'est que
c'est tout le travail qui en vaut la peine et
sinon ça vaut toujours le coup parce que ça
m'a bien aidé encore une fois tu me vois
te figurer jusqu'à  un wagon IV dans la
langue groenlandaise est assez
fort et je pense que c'est très puissant
et que vous vous exprimez, vous pouvez
peindre les fins d'un mot et le rendre
beaucoup plus fort ou beaucoup plus dit
beaucoup plus en colère ou vous savez que c'est c'est
c'est une langue puissante et je suis tellement
reconnaissante de pouvoir la
parler pas je sais que je peux même devenir
leur parler groenlandais mais je suis tellement
reconnaissante de m'avoir gentille oh mon
je suppose que les anciens sont d'importance  Je
pense et et ils peuvent nous aider à
trouver notre identité parce qu'ils peuvent
raconter le bon vieux temps si vous pouvez l'
appeler mais vous connaissez le
Groenland à l'époque parce que nous avons encore
des gens qui se souviennent quand ils
vivaient de la chasse vous savez  Je connais ce
gars de 73 ans dont le premier souvenir est
le bruit de l'eau et il ouvre les yeux
et voit toutes ces femmes grandir dans l'
Umi up tu connais son premier souvenir et wow
c'est l'histoire tu sais c'est 11
peu fort et th  ça m'émeut que nous
ayons des gens qui se souviennent de choses comme ça
et vous savez que j'ai besoin de 24 heures de plus
par jour parce qu'il y a des choses à faire
ici dans la vie et tant d'histoires à entendre
et à rechercher et ainsi de suite et pouvez-vous parler
à  parlez-nous un peu d'un projet que vous
avez en tête impliquant des rappeurs de
différentes parties de l'Arctique et bien je suis
allé aux jeux d'hiver de l'Arctique à
Yellowknife en tant que membre de l'équipe culturelle
j'étais comme technicien sur un
spectacle de théâtre de danse 15 minutes montrent que  nous nous sommes
préparés ici dans le nuke et étant
bien là-bas j'ai apporté mon propre CD pour
commencer et je pensais que je voulais diffuser
cela dans l'Arctique si je peux sachant
que j'allais rencontrer tous ces
gens de l'Arctique je pensais
c'est un bon coup pour moi de juste pret
ma parole et vous savez juste que je ne sais pas
ce que je voulais avec ça mais
ça fait du bien de savoir que mes mots sont
tout autour de l'Arctique d'une manière ou d'une autre vous
savez que cela signifie quelque chose pour moi je ne  Je ne
sais pas si ça veut dire quelque chose  g
pour quelqu'un d'autre mais j'aime le sentiment que
nous vivions tous ces actes culturels
de tous les pays aux Jeux d'
hiver vivaient ensemble dans cette
école, nous avons donc passé de bonnes heures le soir
avec des guitares et avec le
tambour traditionnel et le violon et moi  battre la boxe
et et j'ai remarqué certains des je
me souviens si ça n'allait jamais savoir
quoi mais certains des participants étaient je
pouvais les entendre dans le couloir essayer
de trevor peu et et et c'était
dans leur propre langue mais je  je ne
sais pas qui étaient ces gars mais et
alors vous savez pourquoi ne pas faire un événement oxy kpop
et j'espère que nous pourrons faire
quelque chose à ce sujet je ne sais pas si ça
devrait être ici ou au Canada conscient que ça
pourrait être sympa  pour l'avoir ici
le week-end d'Oak Creek et mais encore une fois
, cela pourrait prendre quelques années avant
que je saisisse cette idée et fasse quelque chose à ce sujet,
sinon si quelqu'un ici est là-bas,
n'hésitez pas à travailler dessus et
je vais danser  être nonne
bye